you know not normally a fan of outraged
mobs but this is one mob that I can I
can get behind that I can join even
people are outraged because the CEO of
Sony hinted that Sony might be cooking
up a remake to The Princess Bride and I
swear if they do that if they do that
there will there will be riots in the
streets and I will be there too throwing
bricks in windows and doing whatever
else I've been waiting for an excuse to
join a riot and and this might actually
be it just leave the princess bride
alone Sony just leave it alone there are
some movies that are there's no
conceivable way to improve upon them
there they're nearly perfect as they are
and and this is one of those here's an
idea if you want to make a movie that's
sort of like The Princess Bride a movie
that's inspired by it a movie that's in
the same vein as it then just make that
movie you know there used to be this
concept of genre in in in film where
you'd have a bunch of movies that have
similar themes similar kinds of plots
but aren't exactly the same and that's
what we call a genre but now it's now
it's just every movies the same so if
someone says you know I think we should
make a movie about people in space you
know and it Owen other-- Star Wars movie
no no just another movie about people in
space oh yeah Star Wars definite let's
make another Star Wars you don't really
have to do that you could just and my
god can you imagine what they would do
to this movie can you imagine the the
woke remake the woke off' occation of
Princess Bride princess Buttercup is a
feminist bisexual you know she the movie
ends when she gives Prince Humperdinck a
an empowering lecture about about
consent and he realizes the error of his
ways and lets him go and then she flees
into the arms of Wesley and and they
agree to have a polyamorous relationship
and of course you have to make one of
the male characters gay probably
probably Fezzik I guess that the giant
and then the Spaniard is trans the trans
year we would call them anyway just just
leave this one alone is all I'm saying
we have to draw a line somewhere for
God's sakes and and I think this is
where we draw the line all right plenty
to get to today and for
side of the game we're gonna talk about
something that is related to to to the
unborn here in a second and but on that
topic the right right to life UK the
organization right to life the UK branch
right to life points out on Twitter that
the Guardian which is a major left-wing
newspaper in the UK they have this
morning on their front page a reference
to unborn babies using that phrase
unborn babies on the front page of the
Guardian and right to life is
understandably celebrating the fact that
this left-wing news organization has
finally decided to use humanizing
language about the unborn because that's
very unusual you never hear the phrase
or read the phrase unborn babies in the
left-wing media except wait a minute I
think we should hold off on throwing a
parade just yet because what's the
headline the headline is again front
page right there the headline is unborn
babies exposed to toxic air pollution
and the article is all about how unborn
babies are affected by air pollution so
you see when polluting when pollution is
harming unborn babies then their unborn
babies but when abortionists are doing
the harming but it's an abortion drug
doing the polluting well then their
fetuses again in other words their
babies when it's politically expedient
for them to be babies and their fetuses
when it's politically expedient for them
to be fetuses so this is not an
improvement
I'm afraid to say this in fact is a
really stark example of the problem
where we grant unborn humans personhood
based on what's most convenient for us
so it's entirely arbitrary so it's not
even we can't even really say that the
pro-abortion side has dehumanized the
unborn that actually would be too
consistent in a way we give them too
much credit when we when we say that
because that would seem too
ply that they have some that they at
least have some sort of consistent
narrative about what the unborn child
actually is but they don't they the
whether or not the being in the womb as
a person really just depends on politics
on convenience it just depends it really
depends so it's entirely arbitrary so
when you ask well where do you draw the
line when is the baby a person the
answer is they don't draw the line
anywhere at least not anywhere not that
they they have no one place where they
draw the line what they would ask you is
well what's the situation so that
humanity the very definition of what
constitutes a person is is now
situational and this provides a
transition into the topic I want to
discuss to begin with because the
Guardian has another story or they had
in a story a few days ago different
story only in this and this is a good
example in this headline the babies were
fetuses again here's the headline more
than two thousand fetal remains found at
home of former Indiana abortion doctor
now the media the leftist media has
given as little attention to this story
as they can possibly get away with they
have had to at least mention it because
it's too big to completely ignore so
they mentioned it they do their article
they didn't you know and they do their
little segment on it and then they move
on quickly and that's what they've
that's what they've done but it is a big
story an abortionist named Eric Klopfer
recently died and it was discovered
after his death that he had the
medically preserved quote-unquote bodies
of over two thousand aborted babies in
his home in Indiana he had these these
trophies in his own 2000 I think about
2000 in his home life cite news has but
this is now in that case their fetuses
because The Guardian is never going to
say oh he's he had the remains of 2,000
babies because if you do that well now
that just sounds that makes abortion
sound horrifying that makes abortion
sound like serial killers which they are
but but the Guardian Guardians on this
also so all of a sudden there they're
back to being fetuses their life site
news has more more information about
this lovely man and the crimes he
committed says the bodies of 2246
aborted babies were found in the home of
a recently deceased abortionist who
previously operated in 2020 Democrat
contender mayor Pete Buddy judges
South Bend Indiana abortionist dr.
Ullrich Klopfer committed abortions at
the Women's Pavilion in South Bend
Indiana home to the University of Notre
Dame and at other Indiana facilities
with his medical light went until his
medical license was suspended in 2016 as
the watchdog group watchdog group
Operation Rescue has extensively
documented Klopfer had a history of
abuses including failing to report
statutory rape of a 13 year old and a 10
year old
he sent the latter home with her parents
who knew their daughter was raped by her
uncle but didn't want him prosecuted and
they didn't report it to the police
a Klopfer is far from the only
abortionist to do this this is a very
common but think about that a
ten-year-old girl raped by a family
member
her despicable evil parents don't want
to report it to police
and Klopfer goes along with it well why
is that because Kloppers a monster back
to the article says the will County
Sheriff's Office announced on September
13 that an attorney representing the
family of dr. Ullrich Klopfer called the
County coroner's office on September
12th to inform them that while going
through the doctors personal property
they discovered what appeared to be
fetal remains and requested that will
County coroner's office provide proper
removal and then skipping head a little
bit they go in they find these 2246 dead
babies although they say that that there
is no evidence that any medical
procedures were conducted at the
property so this raises the question of
was he performing illegal abortions or
something in the home they say there's
no evidence of that and then LifeSite
News points out that this would raise
the possibility that they were aborted
in Indiana and then transported across
state lines which would be a Fed
crime which would mean the federal
government has to get involved now why
would this weirdo this freak and yes in
this case I will happily speak ill of
the dead the dead in this case being the
dead Klopfer why would this disgusting
freak of a person have 2,000 dead
children preserved in his home well
because he was a serial killer and this
is what serial killers do and this is
why as I said this is why the media has
just glanced at this story and moved on
as fast as they possibly could because
it brings to light a really
uncomfortable fact and it raises
uncomfortable questions about the
psychology of people who go into the
business of killing babies and this guy
isn't the only one all right this isn't
and this isn't one case Gosnell you may
remember had a bunch of trophies that he
kept mainly the the hands and feet of
aborted of his of his victims he kept in
jars and so on in in his office in his
home again why why would he do this for
the same reason any serial killer does
it I say this race is uncomfortable
questions for the pro-abortion side of
course it raises many questions but one
of them is is it really possible for
someone to get into the business of
abortion to do this everyday to butcher
babies every day and not end up a deeply
disturbed and deranged person now you'll
say you have to be deeply disturbed and
deranged to get into the business in the
first place and that's true but the job
itself doing the job I think has the
effect of killing off whatever was left
of your conscience whatever conscience
you might have had
however compromised going into this job
I think will be obliterated by the job
there's no way you can retain it think
about the Nazis at Nuremberg the you
know the famous phrase the banality of
evil which which comes from from from
the Nazis at Nuremberg and just just how
they appeared to be these you know they
weren't comic book villains who are
laughing maniacally about about the
horrible things they did these were just
empty people
blank expressions they appear to be
almost bored talking about the slaughter
they carried out because they had done
so much evil for so long they had lost
their souls they had lost their
conscience think about and then and then
that brings to mind think about the
undercover Planned Parenthood videos
which David daleiden of
Senator medical progress is in the
process of being of being legally
persecuted for for those videos but
think about that think about the the you
remember the the joke that one of the
abortionist made about shall get a
Lamborghini for selling dead baby parts
there was that kind of thing laughing
joking about it somehow even more
unsettling though was in many of the
videos what you saw is kind of like
again the Nazis at Nuremberg just this
this serial killer kind of look where
they're so casual about it so almost
bored with it that you think these are
people there's just nothing left inside
their soul is dead men without chess as
what CS Lewis would describe people
without without a conscience anymore and
that's and that's what you have here but
the media doesn't want us talking about
that they don't want us realizing that
makes them very uncomfortable and so
that's why they move on from the story
even though it is a huge huge story all
right
let's a couple of the things I wanted to
talk about and and and we'll start with
this this is some comic relief I guess
of kind of a palate cleanser after the
the sick and disturbing stuff we just
talked about Union Theological Seminary
is a source of never-ending hilarity if
you can find it within yourself to find
heresy funny which which most of the
time I can't but in this case I kind of
do because I just can't help it Union
Theological Seminary is a heretical
outfit they teach the teacher completely
insane version of Christianity if we can
even call it that and they sent out a
tweet today and this is not a joke okay
I will this this this I promise you is
not a joke this is this is real take a
look at this here's the tweet the
tweet says today in Chapel we confessed
two plants together we held our grief
joy regret hope guilt and sorrow in
prayer offering them to the beings who
sustain us but whose gift we too often
fail to honor what do you confess to the
plants in your life I have to say
nothing is what I confessed to the
plants of my life there's a picture of a
person and anything if you can't if
you're not watching right now you can't
see if there is there's a picture of a
person sitting and talking to a group of
plants while a bunch of other people sit
and watch this exchange which I have to
assume was a rather one-sided
conversation if you're if you're
confessing to plants you know and and
they give you a penance to do or
something if they respond if they start
then then you know that there's really a
concern here but all those people
watching here's what's striking about
this photo oh it well the whole thing is
striking but if I had to point to one
particular thing all of those people
watching as this woman sits and talks to
plants none of those people are even
smirking I mean could could you
physically be in that room while this is
happening and not at a minimum smirk
none of them are they're just sitting
there just sitting there is business as
usual and that's how you know the
brainwashing is really working I imagine
that the people who run the Union
Theological Seminary were kind of
standing off to the side off-camera and
rubbing their hands together and saying
yes yes it's working look all I can say
is that I think based on that picture
they are taking VeggieTales way too
literally that's I think that's really
the problem here I wonder I wonder how
these people can manage to walk across
like a grassy field how do they do that
sit there walking I'm sorry sorry sorry
sorry sorry
do they apologize to their Caesar salad
before eating it because that has to be
an awkward conversation listen I don't
know how to tell you this but I'm I'm
good
- well I'm gonna consume you I am really
sorry about that please don't take it
personally or do they not eat salad at
all because that's that's really my
question and I always wonder this
because the people who are most likely
to be idolaters of you know to engage in
this idolatry of plants and this is this
is what you're looking at there that's
paganism okay so this is this is grade-a
paganism on display but the people who
are most likely to do that are also the
people who you know just are almost
certainly vegan there's just no chance
they're not vegan but then there's this
there's this obvious contradiction here
because you're worshipping plants but
then those are also the only things you
eat or do you not eat plants how does
that work I mean it assuming you don't
eat animals but you don't eat plants
because you know plants have feelings
too I mean you can't very well confess
your sins to sit just to someone and
then eat them that it look if that
becomes the process that's gonna cause a
lot of problems in the Catholic Church
it's good things here get pretty dicey
for priests but so then how does that
work so you say you don't eat meat you
don't eat you don't eat plants what do
you eat ceramic you used whatever
someone gives you you dump the food off
the plate and eat the plate one last
thing to think about here is can you
imagine how these people would have
reacted if they saw Jesus curse the fig
tree I mean the son of God would have
got to talking to you on that one could
you just imagine them then witnessing
dancing I wonder if they do they even
keep they must they must rip that part
there must do white out over that part
of the Bible because that would be way
too traumatizing if they were to realize
that Jesus who I they they probably
think is a is was a hippy vegan
socialist to realize that he cursed the
fig tree alright moving on so this is
interesting and I'm interested in your
take on this
in editor at the New York Times now the
New York Times has really been stepping
in it a lot recently and and here we go
again this time it's an editor at The
New York Times named Gina chera loose
probably not how you pronounce it but
that's the best I can do
who apparently has a long history of
offensive quote unquote tweets some
conservatives went through her Twitter
history I don't know why they selected
her for this treatment I'm not sure but
they did and they went through and they
found a bunch of social media posts
going back most back eight nine ten
years ago but a bunch of posts that by
the current rules are racist homophobic
etc now gina herself is a black woman so
she might get away with some of this
stuff there's a lot of stuff where she's
she's insulting white people now that
she's you know that she can do all day
no one's gonna have a problem with that
but there's also a lot of of the the
homophobic stuff which her being a black
woman that's not going to help her there
remember the victim pyramid the victim
hierarchy on the left and remember that
at the LGBT there at the very top of it
so you're you're not now now if you're a
black woman you're pretty close to the
top you're not at the very top so that
could get into some trouble and and for
example she uses the D word for lesbians
she uses the F word for gay men she even
uses the Q word to the trifecta she has
the homophobia trifecta all three words
now a lot of conservatives are saying
saying hey you know these are your rules
now your life has to be destroyed too
okay
we're at work we're gonna play this game
by your rules and she did apologize for
the tweets but the response to her
apology from a lot of conservatives has
been too bad too bad you're sorry
your life has to be ruined you have to
be fired you don't accept it when other
people apologize so we don't accept your
apologize now it's your turn to fall on
that sword and so look first of all I
just
said yesterday that objectively it's
it's very silly to get all outraged
about offensive stuff people said in the
past because we've all said offensive
stuff I just I just went on this spiel
yesterday we've all said offensive stuff
all of us had have many times in our
lives it made you know the the offensive
stuff we we've all said it may be a
different kind maybe it may be it may be
different genres of offensive but we've
all said offensive things so digging up
offensive comments and feigning outrage
is disingenuous stupid malicious and so
on and hypocritical and I've also said
that nobody should ever apologize in
these situations don't apologize to
people who are only pretending to be
outraged and in these situations all F
in every case the people who are
demanding the apology are not really
offended their feelings aren't really
hurt and even if their feelings are hurt
I would I would still say you probably
shouldn't apologize but they're not so
that's even more real why would you
apologize to someone who is only
feigning outrage so that's what I've
said in the past I stand by it but on
the other hand the the argument from the
other side is hey you know she's a
leftist with the New York Times she has
herself endorsed canceled culture as
it's come to be known that this this
culture of quote unquote canceling
people you know getting them fired
shutting them down ostracizing them
alienating them because of things that
they've said that that that you know are
politically incorrect or whatever and
and she's been a part of even yesterday
she was retweeting things that were in
that were approving of the shame you
know Shane Gillis the SNL guy him get
him getting canceled she was she seemed
to approve of that and so she should
take her own medicine that's the
argument and that's the only way leftist
will learn is if they are forced to
experience it themselves and in that
that that seems to be the attitude and
the approach of a lot of conservatives
where they're saying let's let's
but take this stuff and throw it right
back in their face I understand that
argument okay I get it it makes sense
hoist them with their own petard it's
well-deserved no question about that I'm
not going to deny that I mean if you're
out there saying cancel this person
because of the stuff they said and yet
you said similar stuff then shouldn't
you be cancelled to have it you in
effect cancelled yourself already so I
get all that I understand the logic and
and in a way it's sort of impeccable
logic but however I still can't get
behind this I can't get behind digging
up dirt on leftist and calling them for
that for them to be fired and and and
all of that yeah I guess I can't get
behind treating them exactly as they
treat us and I'll tell you why okay I
want to give you my reasons and my
reasons have nothing to do with not
having the stomach for it with being
squeamish with being a wimp about it's
nothing to do I have the stomach to go
toe to toe with these people I you know
I I think if you know if you've been
following me for any length of time I'm
not squeamish I have I have no issue
with upsetting them with with having
people be outraged at me with you know
fighting whatever you want I got no
issue with that I'll do that all day
long
and I think as I said if you follow me
you know if you listen to show whatever
you read my stuff for any length of time
I think you know that's true so and
that's the problems that is that anytime
any conservative tries to say well maybe
this isn't the right approach there
always a kid I'll you win by your just
beer just lying down bowing to the left
no there may be some conservatives who
do lie down and bow to the left but you
know that I don't do that that's not the
way that I play the game I have
different reasons for it and I'll tell
you what my reasons are number one it's
transparently disingenuous it requires
us to act like we're offended by
something that we clearly are not
offended by and I have a
being disingenuous in general I just I
find it to be the most repulsive trait
in people I just I really hate it it's
it's the one thing about a person that I
will that that repels me the most is
being dissing disingenuous nough sin a
person I find really repulsive and so I
can't I can't do it myself
I just can't constitutionally I cannot
do it in any way even aside from that
it's it's pointless because if everybody
knows you're faking it and you know it
and everyone else knows it then what's
the point so if we're sitting here and
we're saying why why I never she used
this language in a tweet I find this
scandalous I'm gonna faint if we're
playing that game meanwhile we don't
really give a crap which we don't
and we shouldn't I mean she don't really
care about that but what this woman said
in a tweet ten years ago you don't care
I don't care what she said she could
have said anything she could have said
the most horrible things you can imagine
I really don't care at all it does not
upset me or offend me I just it doesn't
and so I can't pretend it does and if I
did everybody would know I'm pretending
so why now
second thing more to the point what is
our argument and this really is put put
everything else aside this really is is
the point what is our argument okay when
the left goes and they do their thing
and they try to destroy people based on
past comments and tweets and whatever
what's our argument okay what's what's
our argument against that that approach
our for at least I'll tell you my
argument I think this is all of our our
argument is not oh you shouldn't do that
to this particular person because we
happen to like this person so when they
did this for example to to Kevin Hart
with the whole Oscar thing they you know
and and almost every conservative even
though Kevin Hart is I don't think a
conservative by any stretch of the
imagination but ever
every conservative they were coming out
of there saying this is ridiculous and
our argument wasn't oh don't do this to
poor Kevin Hart Kevin Hart said he's got
a heart of gold
he says it's such a wonderful guy don't
do this to Kevin Hart oh really well it
wasn't about Kevin Hart specifically it
was just don't do this in general to
people you know a joke he made on
Twitter ten years ago whether you like
the joke or not is not a reason for
professional for you know getting them
fired from a job and all that stuff now
and that so that's our argument it would
be a very weak and non winning argument
for us to respond and say oh don't do
that to this particular person because
we happen to like them why would anyone
listen to that argument
no our argument is against cancel
culture in general our counter-attack is
that this whole thing of digging up dirt
trying to ruin people is BS it's wrong
it's dishonest it's manipulative it's
hypocritical it's stupid it's petty we
oppose it that's our argument isn't it
well if we then turn around and do it
ourselves
even in retribution then we've just
forfeited the general on principled
argument against canceled culture we
forfeited the argument against it by
participating in it and the problem is
is that it's it's it's a really good
argument that we're making and this is
point number three related to point
number two this is why I don't want to
forfeit our in general in principled
argument against this kind of thing it's
that our argument is right and it's
winning it is a winning argument III
think I I really believe this more and
more people are are even people who are
ideologically aligned with leftist
values in many ways even even there
there are a lot of people in that camp
who are saying yeah you know I agree
with them on a number of things but I
just can't
I can't be associated with with this
because of because of this because of
this there are a lot of be through the
political correctness all this stuff
there are a lot of people who are just
the outraged mobs the everything the
malicious petty disingenuous
hypocritical way that they go about
things I think that is alienated not
just right-wingers who we don't like
them anyway but it's alienated a lot of
people who are in the middle and a lot
of people even on the left who otherwise
would be you know marching alongside
them but they just can't go along with
it so it is a winning argument and and I
think if if if the right you know if
conservatives whatever that even means
anymore have any chance of winning back
the culture I think it's going to have a
lot to do with the left behavior and us
standing on the other side and saying
that's wrong this is ridiculous
for us to be the sort of even putting
ideology aside for us to be the the the
common-sense consistent just logical
people who can sit there with some of
this madness and say come on guys this
is crazy no no as simple as that
argument is it's very appealing to a lot
of people and and I don't want to
sacrifice I think we are sacrificing it
and we are we are throwing ourselves
into the muck and therefore losing a lot
of the converts that we could otherwise
win and not by sucking up to them but
just by being consistent and
strong-willed and and logical and and
and rational you know being that way I
think wins people it's not weakness at
all to be rational and just and
inconsistent is not weak it's the
opposite of weak that is strength and to
have a little bit of self-control and
exercise a little bit of prudence and to
say sometimes yeah you know what we
could get a scalp here we could take
this person down by
rulz but you know what we're not gonna
do it it's not worth it
that person isn't where that's what we
should say someone like this Gino
whoever her name is I mean who the hell
is she who cares yeah you could take the
scalp you could get her fired you could
you can you can you know sound the
trumpets and and and dance a jig because
because you got that little scalp but
who cares she's not anybody what's okay
i all we've really accomplished is that
we we have once again forfeited our
winning argument there's canceled
culture and we are supposed to be the
ones against it saying we this is wrong
I and I see this a lot now on the right
with conservatives I think we are we are
forfeiting a lot of winning arguments
unnecessarily and we are in effect
joining the left and adopting their
mentality and their philosophy in an
attempt to beat them which of course is
ridiculous because if we become them
then they win what is what what in in
the end does it mean to win what are
they trying to do they're trying to
claim the culture you know to win in
this sense ideologically is for is for
the culture for almost everyone or most
people in the culture to adopt their way
of thinking and their philosophy and
their worldview if that happens then
they win that's what winning means in
this case and so when we join them and
use their tactics then that's just then
that's of them winning even if we claim
one of their scalps in the meantime they
still they still win overall and so I
think that's a mistake all right let's
go to emails Matt well show at gmail.com
Matt well show at gmail.com this is from
channa
I think I think China is CH a and na
hello future supreme dictator Matt
congratulations on your fourth kid I was
just wondering how you go about choosing
possible baby names do your kids have
biblical names do you name them after
family members or or do you just pick
names your
like you know in all honesty I think we
just pick names we like now this is this
is probably not the answer my wife would
give and if I was and if I was you know
maybe it's not always the answer I would
get but I think in reality we do just
pick names we like we pick names that we
think sound good and then retroactively
ly we try to justify them by finding a
biblical figure or saint or historical
figure or family member you know go to
ancestry.com just like find somebody and
so that we could feel like the name has
more meaning than it does but but but I
think I think where it's in that idea is
probably true for most people that when
it comes down to it you're trying to
find a name you just think sounds good
and then you can imagine a kid having
and living with for their whole lives
and so we start there and then we think
well but we don't want to because you
know people are gonna ask us why did you
pick that name and we want to have some
profound sounding reason and so we go
look for one think of a name go flip
through the Bible you know is it in
there somewhere and that's that's
basically our our process alright this
is from Justin says hi Matt love the
show appreciate all you're doing I was
wondering if you could talk a little bit
about the fact that it's been nearly
2,000 years since Jesus's death and
every generation since then has
anticipated his return but yet here we
all are all these years later and hasn't
happened I've been a Christian for most
of my life and I was brought up to
believe maybe mistakenly in the imminent
return of Jesus but I've been struggling
lately with the question where is Christ
and when will he ever return anyway I
would appreciate your thoughts on the
matter
Thanks yeah I think I think you hear a
lot of people these days even which is
what you're alluding to a lot of
Christians or say oh yeah we're living
in the end times this is it this is the
end times you couldn't possibly go on a
later than this I think the people who
say that if they only had I think all
they would have to do is just study
history before you go declare knows the
end times for sure this is it before you
declare that just just
pick up a history book and study history
and what you'll discover is that every
single generation going back before
Jesus has assumed that their generation
was the last one every single one it's
just one generation of another oh this
is it
nope oh this is it nope oh no this is
definitely no oh no no this this is this
is it right now like if you take a
historical view of it you you realize
how silly it is you get a search points
like clearly clearly we are we're
reading the signs wrong here and and we
probably should just stop predicting
because what we're going to be just one
generation in the thousands that has
said this is definitely it it's the end
so you can't do that I think the Bible
makes it clear to no one no one will
know the day or hour and so these are
predictions that just can't be MIT and
in fact I mean you could sit there and
point out all these oh well look at
what's happening here in the world and
here and there I mean this has to be the
end time but okay but think about what
previous generations have gone through
think about the generation that that
think about world war two think about or
world war one you mean the entire world
or much of the civilized world anyway is
literally at war or go back to the to
the to the to the you know when you had
epidemics wiping out large swathes of
the population across the civilized
world the flu epidemic the Black Plague
I mean think about being someone a
peasant in Western Europe while the
Black Plague was just decimating and
killing huge percentages of people all
across that region in the world but
would you have a pretty good reason to
assume that this is this is the end this
is of this is the apocalypse yeah but it
wasn't black plague came killed a lot of
people it went away I didn't completely
go away but you know what I'm saying the
epidemic happened it ended and and
that's it and so all throughout history
there's been that so yeah I think we
at a certain point just have to stop
trying to predict it and there is
something I think also sort of morbid
and weird certainly morbid but also I
would argue kind of weird about it they
were living our whole lives just waiting
for the end of the world do you think
that's really what God wants and I joke
about this too all the time anytime you
hear about a an asteroid that came
within well they call it a close call
they came within a hundred million miles
and that was a close call
shoot then every time I hear about one
of those I say ah man maybe next time
maybe maybe what better luck next time
but in reality that's a joke I mean I
don't actually want the world to be
destroyed okay let me just I'll go out
on a limb and say that I don't really
want the destruction of the world uh I
don't think that's how God wants us to
live I think he wants us to live our
lives we have a life live it don't live
every day just waiting for the world to
be destroyed that's kind of the weird
way to live and I just I don't think
that that's why we're given life now I'm
not gonna get in I'm not saying you know
Yolo you only live once go go live do
whatever you want and that's not what
I'm saying I'm just saying that we are
we are certainly given life to live it
at a minimum and in sitting around
waiting for the end of all things
doesn't seem like a living it just seems
like waiting treading water and I don't
think that's what we're meant to do all
right finally this is from Simon Says
you talked a lot about pronouns
yesterday and you drew the comparison
between demanding that other people use
the wrong pronouns and having pet peeves
you said that you can't demand that
people act differently because you have
a pet peeve and you used people eating
bagels as an example however I wonder if
that holds true when you see people
facetiming in public without earbuds on
or if someone chooses to sit next to you
on the bus even though there are other
there are no other passengers on board
is this an inconsistency in your
statement or is there a difference
between the two please have mercy on me
and my family when you gain power in
spite of my rude question well mercy you
certainly Simon cannot rely upon but you
can rely upon justice I will promise you
that and in your case it will be swift
and likely fatal
what I will say yeah I have in the past
complained about people who face time in
public without putting your buds on
people who sitting next to you on a
plane and the seat right next to you
even though there are other free seats
on the plane where they can get up and
move and give you awesome room and
you're saying isn't that a pet peeve
aren't I being hypocritical well the
answer is no because as I said a pet
peeve is something that you are
unreasonably annoyed by ok it is a
normal perfectly fine activity that
people are engaging in that for whatever
reason because of the way you're wired
you find annoying that's a pet peeve but
if it actually is a rude or strange
thing then if it's not a pet peeve it's
perfectly rational to be annoyed by it
so I can't it would be you you can't say
oh it's my pet peeve when people cut me
off in traffic now that's just something
that annoys you because because it's
rude and dangerous to cut people off in
traffic so it's very logical for you to
be annoyed by it now people who face
time in public without even bothering to
put headphones on and when they could
just be talking on the phone instead
forcing us all to listen to their banal
uninteresting insufferable conversation
that is not only rude but psychotic
behavior and so I have every right to be
enraged by it I have everyone here's
what I'll say I think I am certainly
within my moral rights and I would argue
even my legal rights if you're sitting
at a coffee shop on FaceTime I if within
my moral legal rights to come over take
your phone bring it into the bathroom
and put it in the toilet and flush the
toilet I am that would be totally
justified in doing that and yeah when
you're if you're sitting in the middle
seat on a plane and there's someone you
know on the window seat and nobody shows
up for the aisle seat and you don't move
over again that is psychotic behavior
that is a sign that you are a dangerous
person even
that's a reason you would be justified
in that case to get up and find the Air
Marshal and say this I have suspicions
but see something say something and this
is one of those things because that is
just not normal human behavior all right
but thank you for that question we'll
leave it there thanks everybody for
watching thanks for listening Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by
Robert Sterling associate producer
alexia Garcia Del Rio executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer his
Austin Stevens edited by Donovan Fowler
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina the Matt
Walsh show is a daily wire production
copyright day Lee Weyer 2019 hey
everybody its Andrew Clavin host of the
Andrew Clavin show you know some people
are depressed because the American
Republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moon has turned
to blood but on the Andrew Clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over at the Andrew Klavan
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton